in this video I want to talk about how
we can convert repeating decimals into
fractions so let's give ourselves a
repeating decimal so let's say add the
repeating decimal zero point seven and
sometimes it'll be written like that
which just means that the seven keeps on
repeating so this is the same thing as
zero point seven seven seven seven and I
could just keep going on and on and on
forever with those 7s so the trick to
converting these things into fractions
is to essentially set this equal to a
variable and we'll just sort of do it
step by step so let me set this equal to
variable let me call this X so X is
equal to zero point seven and then the
seven repeats on and on forever
now what would ten X be well let's think
about this 10 X 10 X would just be ten
times this so it would be and we could
even think of it right over here would
be if we multiply this times 10 you'd be
moving the decimal one over to the right
it would be seven point seven seven
seven on and on and on and on forever or
you could say it is seven point seven
repeating now this is the trick here so
we've let me make these equal to each
other so we know what X is X is this
this point seven seven seven repeating
forever ten X is this and this is
another repeating thing now the way that
we can get rid of the repeating decimals
is if we subtract x from 10x right
because x has all these point seven
seven seven seven if you subtract that
from seven point seven seven seven seven
seven then you're just going to be left
with seven so let's do that
so let me let me rewrite it here just
looks a little bit neater 10 ten X is
equal to seven point seven repeating
which is equal to seven point seven
seven seven on and on forever and we
established earlier earlier that X is
equal to zero point seven repeating
which is equal to zero point seven seven
seven on and on and on forever now what
happens if you subtract X from 10x so
we're going to subtract the yellow from
the green well 10 at ten of something
minus one of something is just going to
be nine of that something and then
that's going to be equal to what seven
point seven seven seven seven seven
repeating minus
Oh point seven seven seven and 77 what
going on and on and forever repeating
what's just going to be seven these
parts are going to cancel out you're
just left with seven or you could say
these two parts cancel out you are just
left with seven so you get 9x is equal
to seven to solve for X you just divide
both sides by nine let's divide both
sides by nine well I can do all three
sides although these are really saying
the same thing and you get X is equal to
X is equal to seven ninths let's do
another one let's do another one
leave this one here so you can refer to
it so let's say let's say I have the
number one point to one point two
repeating so this is the same thing as
one point two two two two on and on and
on whatever the bar is on top of that's
the part that repeats on and on forever
so just like we did over here let's set
this equal to X and then let's say ten X
let's multiply this by 10 so 10 X is
equal to it would be 12 point two
repeating which is the same thing as
twelve point two two two on and on and
on and on and then we can subtract X
from 10 X and you don't have to rewrite
it but I'll rewrite it here just so we
don't get confused so we have X is equal
to one point two repeating and so if we
subtract X from 10x what do we get on
the left hand side we get X minus 10x
minus X is 9x and this is going to be
equal to well the two repeating parts
cancel out this cancels with that if two
repeating minus two repeating that's
just a bunch of zero so it's 12 minus
one is 11 and you have nine X is equal
to 11 divide both sides by nine you get
X is equal to eleven over nine